[Music]
john is with us in jacksonville florida
hi john welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave and christina i really
appreciate you taking my call um
question is um probably not typical but
um i'm part of a church board that's
pretty conservative and has
managed to
get themselves out of debt and carry no
debt
unfortunately we're in the middle of a
voting period of deciding whether or not
to do a church remodel and the majority
of the board is
comfortable with
obtaining a 1 million loan to conduct
this
church remodel and
obviously i'm not um i've shared
my opinions i've shared proverbs 22 7
with them and lots of other things i've
learned from you
um but i was just wondering if you had
any guidance on um
maybe
trying to come up with a resolution
well
um
there's a lot of factors at play here
um
i've been in these situations myself um
a couple times
um
number one uh
you don't and i don't believe that debt
is a sin according to the bible
i hope you don't i don't yeah and i i um
but i also can't find a single time in
scripture god used debt to do his work
larry burkett used to say that
there's no no time in scripture
that the amalekites had the israelites
him down in the getting ready to kill
them off in the in in the uh uh in the
canyon and so they did a bond issue
it's just not in there they ran down the
banking alone it's not in there there's
no time there's no positive reference to
debt in scripture and so biblically
speaking
[Music]
debt is stupid but it's not a sin
it's just dumb right okay now you got a
group of people disagree with that on
your board obviously
you've got to reconcile several
different things so you've covered that
issue with them already
um
and
and again i'll quote larry burkett
because he's who taught me a lot of
these things in the especially from a
christian viewpoint or biblical
viewpoint
um
he used to say that too often the church
board looks more like the chamber of
commerce than anything else because it's
people in the church uh
usually men
who are successful business people in
the community and so the pastor and the
congregation looks to the successful
business people to run the business and
the governance of the church and so it's
not unusual for your church board to be
a banker a car dealer an insurance agent
uh
or whatever on there and and so and the
problem with that is they bring their
best ideas
and think that they are the truth rather
than i mean you got a banker on there
that you know rather than
what does scripture say
and so where i think and apparently you
think that scripture ought to be the
baseline the plum line by which we make
these decisions
and so um
then that brings up a couple things all
right then that brings us down to
they're gonna do it anyway right
right well
we're gonna vote on it and decide yeah
we haven't voted yet i mean if you can
if you can persuade enough of them to
use the biblical plumbline
rather than their professional training
to make this analysis
which is what should be done then you
can probably talk them out of it but i
it a lot of times you can't
and i've got you know i've had been in
those situations where the guys i'm
arguing with are friends of mine but
they're just wrong
and so then you've got to decide a
couple things number one i would never
tell someone in a congregation
to leave a church
just because the church took on debt
i'm femininely against it but again i
don't think it's a sin i just think it's
stupid
and if you leave a church every time you
disagree with something the church does
you're gonna be in a different church
every week
because there's always some part of
church is you get to disagree
i mean that's just on you just count on
being upset about something
and if not somebody will make up
something to be upset about and so the
times you should leave a church is when
you have uh lost hope in the
integrity or the wisdom
of the leadership
and the only time i have left the church
is over that where i've lost hope in the
integrity of the leadership or i've lost
hope in the path that they're on i just
cannot align with that but it's never
over a single thing
uh with you know it could be over a
doctrinal issue or something else but
it's never over a single
event like okay i left because they did
this remodel i i would not tell you to
do that
i would though
it would be hard for me to sit in
leadership
on this board if they're going to go in
against something that is a core tenant
of my life
because i'm going to then be endorsing
in a sense my presence if i stay on this
board i'm going to be endorsing what i
believe to be something that is very
very wrong direction
uh again it's not an integrity issue
it's not a salvation issue and that kind
of thing and i'm not telling you to
resign i'm just sharing with you where
my heart is in other words if you were a
congregate i would just say vote against
it make your best case
and then suck it up and if there's no
other reason no other problems with this
church it's still your church
but the fact i'm sitting on this board
says that this has my
name on this stupidity
and i can't
i would struggle with that but
to be very clear though i am not telling
you to do that john and it's one of the
reasons i don't sit on boards i'm on
zero boards
non-profit or otherwise
i don't sit on boards because i'm a
horrible board member
because i'm right and you're wrong i
really don't have any other gear
okay and so that's a weakness of mine
and a strength of mine
and i don't want to impugn that upon you
you're probably a more reasonable person
john you said the church is debt-free
currently right
correct yeah and i wanted to
yeah i'm sorry go ahead how did they get
debt-free have they is it just an older
church that's never had debt or was
there any type of initiative to become
debt free
uh no they've paid off their debt and
and we've been debt free probably for a
few years and uh we do have some
reserves and and my proposal is not to
have absolutes like dave said it's not
yes we do the project but no we don't
how about we do the project in stages um
there is a gc that um
proposed to the church and came up with
these excuses why you don't want to do
that and i'd like to hear if dave has an
opinion since he just finished that
major project um
but that
that was kind of my approach and after
listening to the gc i not only wanted to
take a shower like dave says i want to
watch myself with bleach too so um
which is another problem
you don't trust the guy's integrity you
don't think he's got the best interest
of the client you think he's got the
best interest of his own pocket
right exactly you're hiring the wrong
guy even if you do the rehab
that's a separate issue one more problem
but but the uh but yeah it can
definitely be done in stages any
construction project can be done in
stages is it less convenient yes it's
less convenient
is it um
you know but i you know if i was a
leadership team i would just go before
the church and go hey guys this free
model is something that will help the
cause of the kingdom we can we'll be
able to have more people in here we'll
be able to lead more people to christ
we'll be able to disciple them better
it's a good move spiritually for us to
do this uh you guys need to start
writing some checks so we can do it
right and i think it helps to
have those people that were involved in
the last initiative to pay off debt tell
their stories i was recently on my uh
church board before we moved and we went
through a whole initiative where our
church paid off debt and then of course
board members change out after a few
years and it was nice to have some of
the older board members who had been
through so much of the financials of our
church and have been through they've got
the battle wounds of what it was like to
you know have the stress of being on a
board that's not debt free and some of
the challenges that comes with that what
is that what's the total budget on this
church john
uh right now they're seeing 400 plus 400
000
no not but they're in the green 400 000.
i mean what's the top line what's the
top line
you mean of your total annual income at
this church
well i don't know have those exact
numbers
and you're on the board
yeah i don't have them in front of me i
don't know i mean is it seven million is
it a million what is it no
no no yeah it probably would be a
million somewhere in that range yeah
okay well let me give you another
statistic working with 50 000 churches
you're taking on so much debt there's an
82 percent chance your pastor's gonna be
gone in 36 months
because you're getting ready to strain
this congregation
the pastor fallout with new debt within
36 months is when it's a huge amount of
debt and ratio to their rev revenues
is
it's massive because you're getting
ready to strain the whole system don't
do this please don't let them do this
please you're gonna mess up a whole good
thing oh my gosh
i don't think you can stop them though
it's a runaway train this is the ramsey
show